hello what's a good EQ for playing this
game but I should warn you before you
click play but gain confidence loud
noises fast brightening lights violence
offensive language weird speech weird
English
super mega HD graphics so because
knowledge is power
okay thank you Thank You Victor if that
is your name oh hi how are you doing
okay all right then last move left shift
to run e to use objects pick up right
mouse button to use holded item nice we
were to change item and insuk wit home
restart level so as far as I know as far
as I know this is a baldies basic fan
game or maybe it's not no no no that's
just what everyone was saying about it
so let's go do it
[Music]
[Music]
okay all right thank you
oh oh okay what is what am I looking for
what am I looking at no no no no what am
i oh it's a trashcan why would I need it
why I buy what I need that hello
okay hi bye oh oh okay oh this is odd
and nice actually it's rather pleasant
still don't know what everything's about
but I'm assuming that it's oh wow a
quarter oh boy oh it is
[Music]
okay all right all right okay thank you
thank you very much thank you for that
I'm assuming that uh this is much like
Baldy and that it's not gonna go good
okay all right I'm pretty uh pretty
confident in my abilities here oh hi
hello howdy doody okay how do you oh all
right hello who's there
who is it I'd like to say hi okay
whoa wait a minute Oh another notes book
I got crumpled foil good oh that's a fun
painting over there how are you doing
all right I don't like everything
slamming around over there but let's try
this again okay negative one uh one I
got a cricket that's annoying someone in
the room that I'm just in awe okay ooh
that was some Wow all right so that's
how it's gonna be you can get me at any
time is this what we're dealing with
this is what we're dealing with I shut
up you I was taking this all nice and
slow I was relaxing I was enjoying the
environment the experience as a whole
then you gotta be douche like all right
well let's do this again sorry I'm
trying to do math
this should not so hard for you you can
solve it huh okay alright can do can
diddly doo da can can diddly doing if
you would let I can't click it so I
can't some seems to be problem at there
we go okay
there we go six eight four blue okay
going at someone's uh okay all right so
someone somewhere what's in here whoa
do these look interesting fifty cents
fifty no fifty fifty cents of a euro not
not fifty cents American why don't I go
hey buddy why do I need so much money
daddy's weird without the smacks where's
all my comforting smacks oh so you
you're just oh you're you're exactly oh
hey whoa for my eyes anymore
I don't like the punishment room I think
the punishment room is [ __ ] if you
ask me I think the punishment room is
Garbo all right no I I got killed in
here let's try not to do that what's
this oh hey oh oh oh oh great I hate
this place alright let's try to do math
let's do it eight oh damn it ten five no
please no why do you have an axe
oh okay so he just go thumpy thump
towards you
oh so he no have he no have nothing too
bad what was that okay so he just got
thumpy thump not the worst thing in the
world but I did get a question wrong oh
there he is okay he thumpy thump yeah
okay so he thought me thump oh this is
no good
you thought me thumb but I can get away
okay if I if I take up all of my Baldy
skills I should be able to get through
this okay I don't know what that is oh
okay all right
there's ten notebooks in this one not
just like not just like seven from the
other one there's ten all right well I
can deal with that
why whoa I don't want to be in here
all right oh good
what is this room why is this in a
school whoo okay no exit for me I guess
Oh
hi I'm not running so I guess we're all
good yeah I don't know why there's trash
cans with arrows it must be like a way
that you can throw away stuff that you
don't need that that's the only thing
that I could imagine but I haven't even
seen like a drink thing okay I don't see
him I'm gonna try to get this notebook
here negative six all right 300 that's
that's not good that's not good that's
nothing dad dad dad
oh boy ooh hey hey Oh how fast you going
okay so no not that fast
oh this is the punishment room I don't
like the punishment
[Applause]
doesn't mean was I mean what is it uh
what does it dingdong mean I don't know
what the dingdong means I don't know
what anything does I don't know where
anything is I'm very confused okay but
I'm I'm a ways away
no notebook in there there's a full can
I don't know if this is lemon berry
sweet soda I don't know if this works in
this whoa all right let's do some math
okay nine five seven eleven and two
negative seven six seven and mega five
oh that sounds bad
16 10 16 no oh oh no oh oh no okay all
right we're gonna do it like this oh
okay all right we're fine
we're good to go whoa he mad oh he's mad
okay there she goes I can run who's
laughing who's laughing I've no what is
that all right this is nothing okay all
right this is also nothing okay great
this is a long hallway there's another
long hallway so I imagine it must work
in the same way as the other one right
let's test cuz we have no idea what
we're doing so let's test it out if it's
something good then it's something good
if it's not then I'm screwed
oh it was just an energy oh I need to
throw away cans ah that makes sense
what's it what is this that's what you
need to throw stuff away because if you
use an item it doesn't just go away you
have to use it data make a sense oh and
there's a snack machine all right
so nuts
[Music]
I don't know what's happening and I
don't know where I'm going but I do not
like this adventure that we're on
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
oh oh hello there my name is Victor
Stroh boskie and this is my school but
in your first teacher come to next class
what the hell was that
and I guess that was no bueno I guess
that was bad I guess whatever we did it
was not good and the guy was very very
unbelievably upset so we're gonna take
that in mind but I think I'm starting to
get the strategy it is very similar whoa
hey alright it is very similar to ball
these basics it is very very similar but
before I okay I'm just gonna go a little
faster that's nothing before I do
anything unnecessary like answer a
notebook I'm going to find what a bran
muffin a fluffy chocolate muffin okay
soil what's the point of that what is
the point of that and also what what
what made the lunch lady or lunch man
come at all
Hey
Oh what did you say so if you don't go
to him to cook he cook you okay that's
horrifying
okay all right well you're a cauldron
looks real nice
oh hey oh my uh uh um but it it humble
okay uh hum diddly dum dum all right
avocado that that makes more sense okay
uh okay all right I hate this very much
but it's okay yeah so I don't know I
don't know what whoa whoa hey hey bones
oh you are that's all okay please don't
please don't
where are we going I have no idea what's
happening and I have no idea where we're
going and I don't know why okay cool I
guess we're just gonna get off no okay
I'm just stuck for Ollie I guess this is
just my life now I can't I can't oh
there we go okay finally all right so
just avoid him cuz he's an [ __ ]
I don't know where we are in relation to
the dude Victor he's not as charming as
Baldy I will readily admit not as
charming as Baldy Baldy had a certain
charm to him this guy I know kind of
rubbing me the wrong way all right
what 9 plus 9 plus 1 is 19 screw you
bunch of baloney
that's what that was all right oh this
is this was a dangerous one there's only
one way down here ok let's do it again
all right 2 negative 3 7 life all right
so we got 3 of 10 we're not even close
to where we need to be oh I don't even
want to know what I just saw
hmm all right we're 3 of 10 I don't even
know if we're gonna be able to beat this
one I don't even know if I want to be
able to beat this one I have I have no I
am Bishan one way or another to be able
to beat this one so frankly I think I'd
be okay with just a pleasant experience
I don't know but okay dad's 10 okay I
missed the negative again okay negative
3 negative 4 4 no whoa I missed it again
that's very hard to see okay threes 5
okay yeah I mean I hope you don't need
to be perfect on these but if you do I'm
not going to be perfect
I've said many times that I have many
flaws and I am unperfect oh all right
oh boy okay 4:09 okay and negative one
at negative 7 negative 6 negative 5 0
minus negative 5 would be 5 that's zero
minus five plus nine four oh man it's
like I'm back in school all over again
it's definitely more challenging than
what Baldy eyed going on I'm gonna say
maybe Victor's a little bit smarter yeah
I think I got to make my way back to the
cafeteria at some point soon maybe now
that I represent sure but okay oh
there's another one I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to find the cafeteria again I don't
know where it was in relation to where I
am and that might be a bad thing but
like oh hey there you are
okay sounds like I might need to get
back to the cafeteria what did i do what
did I thought that gave me energy
I thought that gave me energy did that
knock you mean oh gee
Oh what about a bran muffin a a bran
muffin will give me energy
what does it what does it can do what
does it can oh boy wait no how did we
we're oh no wait I just ordered my stuff
no don't you dare oh okay all right
we're good I'm fine I need to get back
to the dude or he's going to be very mad
I think the Bell might have something to
do with that right that would make a lot
of sense to me
oh oh oh I thought that music was like
queuing up the chef to come barreling
down the hallway that's just him okay I
don't recognize these paintings I still
don't have like a layout of this area in
my head oh that's not good okay I don't
like the open learning environment of
that place yeah you're the can sound
like I'm pissing my pants am i just
squeezing it all over myself like I'm a
jogger I'm like oh gosh
sugar is hot out here I have no idea
where I am I really don't know I'm lost
and alone and scared and I don't know
where the cafeteria is maybe oh yeah hey
oh hey I'm here don't be sad don't be
mad I'm here it's all good tomato
[Music]
so for this next one I'm not going to
I'm not gonna try to get the notebooks
what I'm gonna try to do is I'm trying
to get an idea of the entire environment
now that I know what it's all about now
that I know what it can do I think I can
do this a little bit better okay yeah
now that I now that I know what's going
on I think I'll be a little better about
it so the the cafeteria I believe is
around the so that's the punishment room
okay so that's Punk room she went away
and I can run there's a classroom this
is okay that leads to the two down the
branching hallways there's another
classroom okay this is the classroom and
a weird punishment room I don't know why
that exists maybe that's supposed to be
a bathroom but I think you need some
toilets and or a drain to have a
bathroom maybe some cow cake this is
where the cafeteria is so it's down the
hallway with a lot of things let me go
ahead and make him happy first
so you smiling now he wasn't smiling
before said a mustache person you know
for corn back off oh it's a black male I
don't know oh okay thank you
all right thank you so I probably got to
talk to him like every five minutes or
so okay so the cafeterias and the branch
in between the yellow walls and the
white wall are the wooden walls okay so
this is like a a junction here to rice
bowl Kitty's the classroom oh no that's
the stage okay so they're randomly
they're randomly generated which is a
problem but not that big of a problem
I'm just wondering if there's any more
items to discover okay this is just a
classroom with weird trash
why is there so much trash here do I get
a reward if I clean up all the trash
okay all right I feel good about this
I feel real accomplished look how good a
student I am teach doesn't it make you
will not want to kill me dead oh come on
teach we're all in this together we got
a fight for planet Earth yeah I don't
think this does anything what is the
point of this is there a way to like
recycle this stuff and get money out of
it that's not just a trash can is that
is that what this is about like maybe
maybe there's some mechanism by which to
let get some money out of this side so
that's a double hallway so that leads
down to areas someone pointed out
earlier that it may like the can of soda
may drop on the floor and like cause
someone whoa hey dude we saw solder how
you doing all right
I think this is gonna connect back in a
big loop because it's got to be at least
one loop there are some dead ends though
I was hitting before but there's got to
be at least one loop
where does that go this is another
classroom visit classroom with all the
math on the walls this is empty
classroom I don't recognize that
classroom there's so many classrooms
there's so many places for these to be
there's no way that I'm gonna be able to
do this oh is that him yeah it's him
okay he's a common
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
okay I think that must be where the loop
is so that's where he loops around this
is the double room with lots of trash I
think there's a cut isn't wasn't there a
cut in here yeah so this must that's
just a big hallway often an accessory
but this is where he just came in and
that was the loop that we just made yeah
he's right there okay that's good to
know
is he getting faster as time goes on
because that's extremely unfair
that's excessively unfair that's too
unfair okay there's goatman
all right there's vendo machine oh wait
a minute wasn't this the dead end well
how did he how did he come from the dead
end how in the world did he come down
the dead end okay so the answer is
probably you need to do the long hallway
first so that you can get these these
math questions that are in the dead end
hallways but that doesn't make any sense
there's nothing in here okay but I can
get this and choco bar and I think I can
get some energy out of the nuts so if I
just put the nuts in my body I should be
fine but I'm gonna wait for him to come
in here all right
there you are hey big boy how you doing
come on in come on don't be shy come on
come on in come on in come on
that's not the direction I wanted you to
take he is not going any faster I don't
I probably got to get back to the
cafeteria man pretty soon maybe the
maybe the sweeper man broomed him down
here that's the only thing that I can oh
there's a window there so I can actually
check if there whoa
do not broom him to me whatever you do
do not broom him to me okay
knead the nuts I'm gonna get back to mr.
dude man
cafeteria man because he's probably
really upset so apparently this does not
loop back to the other side of the the
school this is just this is just its own
section wait no that was the double whoa
hey whoa what I was on my way wait
[Music]
now see here I was on my way I was on my
way
I think I know everything that I need to
know I probably definitely need to go
over to the yellow section first just to
be able to get the more difficult ones
that are kind of cornered off I don't
want to get cornered over there okay
let's try this for real if this works it
works if it don't work then I'm boned
and I don't need to worry about anything
at all okay she's gonna be wrapping
around that way yellow because it wasn't
I thought wait are there I thought
wasn't the cafeteria like right here
wasn't it am I crazy am I out of my
gourd my honestly out of my gourd wait a
minute but hang on I'm not crazy I might
be crazy I'm probably crazy I'm probably
in stupid whoa hey um oh okay all right
I'm sorry I didn't mean to go that way
hey what's up okay apparently I'm not a
lady apparently I'm not crazy but
Oh Oh
that's the bridge okay oh whoa hey whoa
well I just well I threw that I threw
the muffin what does that do what did
the muffin do what are these items do I
thought it was like food gave me energy
but apparently not oh that's not a
bridge that's just a this is a doorway
with the worst okay candy gave me that
candy gave me energy
I'm so confused my big giant massive
brain is having trouble processing Oh
candy no candy gives me unlimited energy
for a little bit nuts the nuts really
give it to you
[Music]
okay where it is where oh where where oh
where is the cafeteria where the heck
and where what hotdog okay all right
wanton oh oh that makes more sense okay
I get it
man I cannot understand that guy's
accent I just don't get it it's weird
alright so this is two paths I don't
know if one leads okay so this is this
is this is this place I mean
just go ahead I'm now gonna win this
round I know that for a fact but oh boy
blah blah there's two math books in here
that's weird
okay good to know all right um okay man
I wish I didn't have to click it why do
I have to click it I just want to be
able to hit the enter button and be able
to get it and with that it's just a pain
in the ass okay this leads down to the
hallway by itself no I'm wrong again
damn it oh that leads down to the
hallway by himself he must have looped
back there because of the sweeper man
and then then he came out of here and it
just seemed like he was going around in
a circle but this is a loop but this
leads back to the cafeteria the other
way okay now I'm getting it is there
even anything in there none that one hmm
okay I'm good I'm good I'm just figuring
this out trying to get it under my belt
it's a bit confusing but I think I'm
doing better than I was all right
there's something here just a quarter
but I want that uh fine damn it
okay he's probably gonna be pissed about
that
I gotta figure out what the soda does
eventually okay there's nothing in here
I knew that already
oh okay oh no no not now not you son of
a okay can you just can I please can I
just can't okay
all right we're I do not want to be on
okay I guess this is good this is good
this is good this is good this is good
this is good this is good this is good
this is good I gotta get to the
cafeteria do you think you can swing by
and drop me off you think you can swing
by hell yeah
okay all right okay all right cafeteria
which way I think it was this way I
think I'm almost positive yeah yeah
because it was right at the junction
between this and that hey buddy
oh you look upset hey it's okay it's
okay
you said Pete Opie is amazing okay so he
he's like the time check so he's like if
you can't beat this game in a certain
amount of time he's gonna get you cuz it
seems like he's really upset and I don't
want to make him upset but I guess I got
to return more frequently than I have
been
can I have this please thank you I don't
know where he is but he's close this is
a bad idea why am I doing this
uh-oh this is dumb okay no I'm not gonna
be I'm not gonna be able to get all
these oh oh hey look listen buddy oh no
that's too fast that's too fast that's
that's unfairly fast that's that's a bit
too fast you need to not do that you
need to absolutely not do that
okay well I'm screwed
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to win
this at all but I do know that this
guy's kind of an [ __ ] but hi bahaar
body hey hi body hi heids listen to me
with me reasonable Bob this oh okay wait
word oh wait no this big does loop this
is the loop this right here is the loop
that that's the loop that leads no wait
no it's not the loop never mind I'm an
idiot
never mind huh I'm an idiot now I'm out
of sprint hey you want a soda uh dropped
it on the ground maybe I don't know hey
whoa I'm gonna go say hi to the chef a
lot I'm gonna give him a big old smooch
on his like rope nose and he's gonna
he's gonna love me he's gonna love me I
still don't know what the can do
whatever
okay let's try not to get any wrong okay
five six nothing okay cuz it was
probably because I got so wrong so many
wrong that he was really coming after me
so I'm just happy
not do that I bet I can get this one
before he comes around the game I bet I
bet I bet there we go why no right oh oh
no I deserve to die I deserve to die oh
if he gets me I deserve it
I'm outie hi Maddie I'm outie baby
there's none in there mister man I can
get some nuts with this I'm in I'm in a
math you can't you can't guy you can get
me oh oh oh hey oh mom wait no warning
when you already remember all the rules
oh my god oh [ __ ]
my parents will be dissatisfied when I
well I think that's a boy so I think
that's a good enough place to stop this
I can already tell if I were to try to
take this game seriously and try to beat
it it would take me hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours and hours of attempts and I do not
feel like doing that baldie I like
playing the normal game to completion
was fine like this is not that this is
like hard mode this would be this would
be the nine hours that it took me to get
through hard mode and I'm not gonna do
that no no no no no no no no no no no no
so smooching that one goodbye and I'll
leave this one too
the rest but not that not that not that
well made I will give it that well made
[Music]